Pionnier du cinéma ethnographique, Jean Rouch
a passé plus de soixante ans de sa vie à
parcourir le Niger, le Mali, le Ghana ou encore
la Côte d’Ivoire pour produire des films
documentaires et des fictions comme on n’en
avait jamais vu. Sa caméra a mis à la portée
du grand public des traditions inaccessibles
telles que les rituels des Dogon du Mali et
illustré les enjeux contemporains de l’Afrique
de l’Ouest, en donnant la parole aux migrants,
aux travailleurs et à la jeunesse.
Au-delà de l’émerveillement que procurent
les images de terrain, et sans prétendre
être exhaustif puisque sa filmographie compte
près de 130 films, je vous propose un retour
sur le travail scientifique et artistique
de Jean Rouch. Celui qui a montré qu’on
peut à la fois conduire un travail de recherche
de terrain et être un cinéaste parmi les
plus influents de son époque.
On a déjà parlé de film ethnographique
quand on avait évoqué le travail de Margaret
Mead et Gregory Bateson en Indonésie, mais
le film n’était pour eux qu’un support
de travail, un moyen et pas une fin. Le livre
restant l’objet le plus valorisé dans une
perspective universitaire. Les ethnologues
publient à cette époque de grandes synthèses
sur les peuples qu’ils étudient. Ils interrogent
les anciens sur le passé et les traditions,
théorisent les fonctions des institutions
sociales, etc. Et le cinéma ne paraît pas
avoir sa place dans cette entreprise, il peut
collecter les faits mais certainement pas
les analyser.
C’est sans doute un préjugé qui colle
au cinéma depuis son origine, depuis les
frères Lumière qui envoyaient leurs opérateurs
partout dans le monde pour filmer sans mise
en scène et sans montage, des panoramas et
des scènes du quotidien.
Mais Rouch lui, veut faire avec les images
animées autre chose qu’un préalable à
l’écriture, il veut en faire du cinéma.
En réalité, d’autres cinéastes se sont
essayés avant lui à un cinéma documentaire
au plus près du réel. Parmi eux, il y en
a deux qui ont exercé une influence durable
sur Jean Rouch.
Le premier est Robert Flaherty, le réalisateur
de Nanook of the North, sorti en 1922. Ce
film, que Jean Rouch voit à l’âge de six
ou sept ans, est un choc esthétique profond.
Flaherty rapporte des images époustouflantes,
tournées dans des conditions extrêmes et
qui témoignent de la condition humaine de
manière universelle.
L’autre cinéaste qui a beaucoup compté
est Dziga Vertov, inventeur soviétique du
kino-pravda, le cinéma-vérité. A l’avant-garde
de la production audiovisuelle, il refuse
tout recours au spectaculaire. Dans L’homme
à la caméra, sorti en 1929, il montre une
unité de lieu et de temps, sans scénarisation,
et expérimente de nombreux effets de montage.
A la fin des années 1930, Jean Rouch est
élève de l’Ecole nationale des Ponts et
Chaussées et fréquente en auditeur libre
les cours d’ethnologie de Marcel Mauss à
Paris. Diplômé en 1941, il décide de fuir
l’occupation allemande et accepte un poste
d’ingénieur dans les colonies africaines
pour y superviser des travaux publics. A 24
ans, il se retrouve à la tête de 20 000
ouvriers africains, à qui il fait construire
des routes à travers le Sahel. Mais Rouch
a honte de son travail, et de l’attitude
des colonisateurs. Il veut se mêler aux Africains,
se prend de passion pour les rituels qu’il découvre.
Ces films ont été faits comme les autres films que j'avais fait jadis
Ce sont simplement des documents montrant des scènes de la vie quotidienne
Un jour, dans un village songhay, dix hommes
du chantier sont tués pendant un orage, et
un rituel de possession est organisé pour
apaiser l’esprit responsable de leur mort.
Grâce à ses amis nigériens, notamment Damouré
Zika, pêcheur sur le Niger qui devient un
ami indéfectible, Rouch assiste au rituel
de possession. Il prend des photographies
et publiera ainsi son premier article ethnographique
« Aperçu sur l’animisme sonraï ».
Après-guerre, en 1946, il décide avec deux
amis ingénieurs français, de descendre le
fleuve Niger en pirogue de sa source jusqu’à
l’océan, soit un périple de 4200 kilomètres.
Avec une caméra 16 mm achetée la veille
du départ au marché aux puces de Saint-Ouen,
et dont il apprend à se servir au fur et
à mesure, Jean Rouch ramène de nombreuses
images mais qui sont très difficiles à exploiter.
L’image bouge sans cesse, et les raccords
sont impossibles, parce qu’il filme alternativement
les deux rives du fleuve, ce qui entraîne
la confusion du spectateur. Ces premières
erreurs lui font prendre conscience d’une
règle de base, il faut penser au montage
dès le moment du tournage.
Il parvient tout de même à vendre un court-métrage
(Au pays des mages noirs, 1947) à une production
parisienne, mais les commentaires hors contexte
et limite racistes superposés à ses images
remontées dans le désordre, le convainquent
de se charger lui-même de la post-production
pour ses prochains travaux. C’est ce qu’il
fait dans Les magiciens du Wanzerbé, tourné
en décembre 1948 et dans Initiation à la danse des possédés.
Le client insiste alors Mossi va lire dans la terre.
Il attache la brousse. Dit "La terre ne ment pas"
Puis, il jette les étoiles.
Ces deux films comportent
encore de nombreux défauts, la bande-son,
le commentaire et les plans manquent peut-être
de nuance, mais les bases du cinéma rouchien
sont là. Plusieurs de ses premiers films
sont primés en festival.
Lorsqu’il retourne en Afrique en 1950, c’est
avec plusieurs bourses, en plus du CNRS où
il a désormais un poste de titulaire, le
CNC et l’IFAN soutiennent désormais son
travail. Cela lui permet de commander un magnétophone
dernier cri mais malheureusement très lourd.
On l’oublie aujourd’hui mais les conditions
techniques sont à l’époque assez difficiles.
Les pistes sonores ne peuvent pas encore être
enregistrées en même temps que les images
et la caméra portable à ressort ne permet
pas de faire des prises de plus de 25 secondes
consécutives. Pour éviter le faux raccords,
Rouch veille désormais à changer d’angle
de vue entre chaque prise.
Jean Rouch commence en 1950 à abandonner
l’idée un peu naïve qu’il ne serait
qu’un observateur neutre des situations
qui se déroulent devant lui. Conscient de
sa responsabilité dans la manière de représenter
les événements, il commence à accepter
de manipuler légèrement les images et les
sons, pour donner une représentation plus
fidèle de la réalité.
Il filme notamment lors de ce voyage d’étude,
Cimetières dans la falaise, réalisé à
Bandiagara, chez les Dogon où il a retrouvé
Marcel Griaule. Celui-ci lui apprend qu’un
homme est mort noyé dans un torrent et charge
Rouch de filmer les cérémonies de son enterrement.
Le film montre notamment le corps hissé au
bout d’une corde dans une cavité de la
falaise où il doit reposer.
Durant le même voyage, en 1951, il filme
une cérémonie de yenendi, consistant à
provoquer la pluie.
Là-haut dans les nuages noirs, les dieux du ciel sont à l’œuvre.
Moussa a demandé les nuages et la pluie.
[nom dieu] a forgé les pierres de la foudre
Il filme aussi une chasse
à l’hippopotame dans Bataille sur le grand
fleuve, entreprise qui, de la fabrique du
matériel de chasse et cérémonies préalables,
jusqu’à la traque et la mise à mort de
plusieurs animaux, dure presque trois mois.
Mais le film le plus marquant de cette période
reste sans aucun doute Les Maîtres fous,
tourné en 1954. Il montre un rituel de possession
en Gold Coast, le Ghana actuel, par des haukas,
des génies songhay, un culte importé par
les immigrants nigériens. Ce rituel emprunte
certains aspects du protocole colonial, mettant
en scène le gouverneur, général, caporal
de garde ou la marche des soldats britanniques
mais aussi sacrifice d’animaux, notamment
un chien dont on boit le sang et mange la
chair. Transe collective qui manque de dégénérer
à plusieurs moments, elle se termine sur
l’image apaisée de ses participants retrouvant
leur vie normale après la cérémonie.
La première projection au musée de l’Homme
à Paris est un scandale, on réclame même
la destruction du film, qui dévaloriserait
les Africains et alimenterait des préjugés
racistes. En Gold Coast au contraire, le film
est interdit car il se moque de l’ordre
colonial britannique. Néanmoins, le film
est primé à la Mostra de Venise et au festival
de Cannes. A rebours des films ethnographiques
cherchant à archiver les traditions ancestrales,
Rouch est parvenu à montrer l’évolution
des pratiques religieuses en train de se faire,
dans la lignée de ce que fera Georges Balandier
dans Afrique ambigüe, sorti deux ans plus
tard en 1957.
Nous allons te raconter une histoire. Quelle histoire ?
C'est notre voyage de Kourmi Ghana
Que l'on appelait dans le temps Gold Coast, la Côte de l'Or.
Là où les gens vont chercher de l'argent, des habits et toute la richesse.
Toujours en 1954, Rouch tourne Jaguar, dont
il n’achèvera le montage qu’en 1967 faute
de moyens. C’est cette fois-ci une vraie
fiction, même si les codes du cinéma-direct
documentaire sont volontairement appliqués.
On retrouve notamment Damouré Zika et Lam
Ibrahima Dia qui accompagnent désormais Rouch
dans tous ses tournages. Les dialogues entre
personnages sont en voix-off par exemple.
Il raconte l’histoire de trois amis, jeunes
hommes qui veulent quitter le Niger pour rejoindre
la Gold Coast. Ils réunissent de l’argent,
demandent la bénédiction des dieux et se
jettent sur la route. Les trois amis traversent
des territoires étrangers, et s’étonnent
de ce qu’ils voient, dans une sorte de road-movie
ethnographique.
Voilà je suis venu en promenade, je veux passer de l'autre côté, comme une simple promenade quoi.
Les péripéties du voyage sont improvisées au fur et à mesure, mais
cette fiction raconte pourtant une histoire
vraie, celle des migrants nigériens qui tentent
de trouver du travail dans les grandes villes
de la côte.
Eh ben mon vieux y'a pas moyen.
J'ai été voir le policier, l'anglais.
"Carte d'identité, douane, police"
C'est des gros couillons, hein ?!
Cette première expérimentation trouve son
aboutissement dans Moi, un Noir. Cette
fois-ci c’est en Côte d’Ivoire que Jean
Rouch filme en 1956 deux jeunes immigrés
Nigériens. L’acteur principal, Oumarou
Ganda, qui deviendra plus tard cinéaste,
est à l’époque un docker nigérien du
port d’Abidjan. Il raconte sa vie, parle
en son nom propre, interpelle même Rouch et sa caméra.
Pour moi c'est seulement le samedi soir que je suis heureux.
En dehors du samedi soir, toute ma vie est troublée.
Rouch veut lui laisser la parole
et raconter d’une autre manière ce qu’il
a déjà montré dans Jaguar, sur un ton plus
léger.
Il faut que je sois moi aussi un homme heureux. Comme tous les hommes.
A sa sortie, Moi, un Noir reçoit
un accueil chaleureux et Jean-Luc Godard publie
trois articles sur le film dans les Cahiers
du cinéma. Le film reçoit par ailleurs l’un
des prix les plus prestigieux du cinéma français,
le prix Louis-Delluc.
Les années 1960 voient Rouch s’intéresser
à Paris même s’il continue à se rendre
très souvent au Niger. Avec Edgar Morin en
1960, il réalise Chronique d’un été,
sans doute son film le plus célèbre, qui
reçoit le Grand prix de la critique au festival
de Cannes. Les progrès techniques lui permettent
d’enregistrer jusqu’à trois minutes d’affilée
d’image et son synchrones sur une caméra
légère pour demander aux Parisiens :
« Êtes-vous heureux ? »
Ça dépend c'que vous appelez heureuse.
Heureuse, je suis heureuse en ménage oui.
Rouch et Morin se réclament
alors du “cinéma-vérité”, mais le terme
fait rapidement débat et l’appellation
"cinéma-direct'' est préférée à partir de 1963.
Rouch filme ensuite La pyramide humaine (1960)
qui traite des relations entre Européens
et Africains en Côte d’Ivoire à travers
une classe mixte du lycée d’Abidjan. Le
tournage est chaotique et le tournage avec
les adolescents n’est pas aussi convaincant
que prévu. Le film a toutefois le mérite
d’aborder frontalement le racisme et de
montrer un amour naissant entre une adolescente
française et un ivoirien, scandaleux à l’époque,
au point d’être interdit longtemps en Côte d’Ivoire.
En parallèle, il suit les cérémonies dogons
du Sigui, qui se tiennent sur sept années
consécutives entre 1967 et 1974.
La version finale sort sous le titre de Sigui synthèse.
Cette cérémonie qui se déroule tous les
soixante ans lui avait été racontée par
Marcel Griaule mais celui-ci, mort entre-temps,
n’aura jamais pu y assister. Quand le rituel
s’apprête enfin à être célébré, l’ethnologue
Germaine Dieterlen (prononcer Diétèrlin)
lui propose d’aller le filmer. Toutefois,
Rouch ne comprend pas vraiment ce qu’il
filme. Au fur et à mesure des années, et
grâce aux Dogons qui commentent certaines
projections, un schéma général apparaît.
Il s’agit de rejouer la création du monde
et les étapes de la naissance des humains,
et en particulier l’invention de la parole
et de la mort.
Les hommes se rasent soigneusement entre eux, pour être comme des nouveaux-nés.
En 1967 sort l’un des films les plus salués
par la critique, Lion d’or du Documentaire
à Venise, et pourtant assez décrié par
les ethnologues : La chasse au lion à l’arc.
Cette histoire les enfants vous ne la vivrez sans doute jamais.
Car, quand vous serez grands, personne ne chassera plus jamais le lion à l'arc.
Dans ce film, Rouch pose un décor poétique,
le Pays de Nulle Part, en réalité la frontière
entre le Mali, le Niger et le Burkina Faso.
Il filme les chasseurs Gow qui partent à
la chasse au lion, et le relate comme un conte.
Un lion s’attaque depuis peu au troupeau
et les chasseurs décident de l’abattre.
La première expédition est un échec, et Rouch revient pendant plusieurs années.
Et soudain c'est la catastrophe.
Le lion charge avec son piège, rattrape un berger Peul.
Je m'arrête de tourner mais le magnétophone continue à enregistrer.
[lion rugissant]
Alors, c'est le miracle. au moment où
les autres bergers attaquent à coups de lance, le lion meurt.
Dans Petit à Petit tourné en 1968,
Rouch fait jouer à Damouré Zika le rôle
d’un ethnologue nigérien à Paris, prenant
notamment les mesures des Parisiens, dans
un renversement total de la science coloniale.
Mais en réalité ces parisiens, ils sont pas beaux, d'abord ils sont trop petits
puis ils sont pas tellement gros.
Il continue après ça à voyager et à produire
des films pendant encore trois décennies,
et on va donc arrêter là notre aperçu de
sa filmographie.
Tu vois Morin, l'idée de réunir des gens autour d'une table est une excellente idée.
Seulement, je ne sais pas si
nous arriverons à enregistrer une conversation aussi normale qu'elle le serait
s'il n'y avait pas de caméra.
Rouch n’est pas un idéologue ou un militant.
Il se méfie par exemple de la démarche de
Chris Marker, qui est pourtant son ami et
dont les méthodes sont assez proches des siennes.
Alors si tu crois cela, tu iras en enfer ? Alors mes ancêtres sont partis en enfer.
Alors j'ai dit je préfère aller en enfer avec mes ancêtres, que d'aller au ciel avec
je sais pas qui
Il revendique pour sa part un « anarchisme
sans militantisme », dégoûté par la corruption
et l’hypocrisie qu’il croise dans les
milieux coloniaux et les jeunes Etats africains
indépendants. Il n’aborde jamais ces questions
politiques dans ses films, ce qui lui a d’ailleurs
été reproché, mais il ne voulait pas émettre
un jugement avec des valeurs européennes,
et paraître impérialiste.
Le concept clé de sa filmographie reste finalement
celui “d’anthropologie partagée”. Ni
militant ni bienfaiteur, il filme d’abord
par plaisir personnel, et pour montrer une
réalité au plus grand nombre. A l’opposé
de l’extorsion d’information que Marcel
Griaule opérait chez les Dogons, Rouch conçoit
la relation entre l’ethnographe et son interlocuteur
comme un échange. C’est pour cela qu’il
organise souvent des projections en Afrique
pour les personnes qu’il a filmées. Ces
projections donnent lieu à de véritables
séances de réflexion, et les spectateurs
orientent souvent la suite du projet, en proposant
de nouvelles idées qui débouchent sur de
nouveaux films.
Le partage est aussi celui de ses amis et
complices de tournage. Ce sont en particulier
Damouré Zika et Lam Ibrahima Dia, qui sont
acteurs, scénaristes et assistants. Avec
Rouch, le trio prend le pseudonyme de Dalarou,
qui apparaît au générique de Cocorico ! Monsieur
Poulet (1974). Moussa Hamidou, preneur de
son et complice, participe lui aussi à tous
les films tournés au Niger. Ensemble, ils
partagent les recettes des films.
Mort d’un accident de voiture au Niger en
2004 et enterré au cimetière de Niamey,
Jean Rouch est, paraît-il, devenu un génie
du fleuve.
J’espère que cette vidéo vous aura donné
envie d’aller découvrir quelques-uns de ses films.
N'hésitez pas à commenter, liker et surtout soutenir financièrement la chaîne si vous le pouvez.
via Utip ou Tipeee.
Je vous remercie et je vous dis à la prochaine, salut !